l'affaire du sang contaminé revisité
grâce à ce documentaire signé par
Mélanie d'Alsace et tirée de la série
les mensonges de l'histoire ou comment
vous venez de le voir au cœur des années
80 les centres de transfusion sanguine
des médecins et les pouvoirs publics ont
sciemment autorisé la circulation de
stock de sans contaminé par le virus du
sida contaminant par la même les
hémophiles les transfuser et leurs
proches quelles leçons pouvons-nous
aujourd'hui tirer de ce scandale d'État
et bien nous allons débattre maintenant
avec nos invités présents sur ce plateau
de débat doc en commençant par vous Eric
favro bienvenue à vous bonjour vous êtes
journaliste grand reporter au quotidien
Libération vous êtes spécialiste des
questions de santé et ce depuis 1986 on
était à un moment où l'omerta la plus
complète régnait sur cette affaire et
bien sûr on y reviendra ensemble durant
toute cette émission jean-Louis Touraine
est également avec nous bienvenue à vous
jean-Louis Touraine vous êtes professeur
de médecine ancien député la République
en marche
du Rhône la République en marche c'était
avant Renaissance aujourd'hui ça
s'appelle Renaissance ce groupe ici à
l'Assemblée nationale et vos recherches
sont entre autres durant votre carrière
médicale concernée le VIH et les
déficits immunitaires on vous remercie
beaucoup d'être sur ce plateau et puis
enfin avec nous Jean-Louis Dubourdieu
bienvenue à vous vous êtes ancien
président de la FH l'Association
française des hémophiles vous avez été
vous-même contaminé à l'occasion d'une
de transfusion sanguine par le VIH
racontez-nous comment ça s'est passé à
quelle époque ça s'est passé
visiblement assez tard dans les
probablement les années 85 d'après les
réactions
très simplement j'utilisais des produits
qui étaient beaucoup plus pratique à
utiliser que les produits anciens qui
étaient
des produits qui remplacés chez moi les
facteurs de coagulation qui me
manquaient
ça ne m'empêchait pas de vivre mais tout
à coup c'est ces médicaments étaient
beaucoup plus pratique à utiliser
et c'était fantastique on était
beaucoup plus libre moi je me souviens
étudiant j'avais il m'arrivais de me
faire une transfusion il était même
arrivé de
de faire une transfusion avec accroché
le flacon à la portière de ma 4L donc
c'était un peu un peu acrobatique des
fois et là on avait un petit flacon et
un jour
il y avait quelques
[Musique]
quelques rumeurs mais les médecins et le
médecin que je connaissais depuis fort
longtemps depuis
15 ans ou plus
c'est non tout va bien quoi et
un jour j'ai appelé on m'a testé et j'ai
appelé c'était je pense en 85 on m'a dit
oui oui j'ai appelé au téléphone on m'a
dit bah oui c'est positif et il va
falloir aller voir un médecin et ah bon
un virologue c'était nouveau dans ce
cursus médical que nous suivions tous
depuis notre petite enfance et vous
aviez atteint était atteint pardon par
le VIH oui c'est la trithérapie qui plus
tard vous vous sauvera la vie oui oui
vraiment sauvé la vie parce que après
avoir essayé tout un tas de de molécules
plus ou moins efficace et plus ou moins
délétère j'arrivais effectivement au
bout de
mon parcours médical et heureusement les
trithérapies sont arrivés à point nommé
je crois que c'était en 96 quelque chose
absolument ce médecin dont vous parlez
vous le connaissiez depuis 10-15 ans
vous lui avez fait confiance absolument
est-ce que lui savait vous n'allez
reparler avec lui par la suite non et je
n'ai pas reparlé mais bien sûr qu'il
savait je crois que quand vous avez en
France une petite centaine de
spécialistes qui communiquent beaucoup
bien sûr qui savent bien sûr que les
parents entre eux bien sûr qui parlaient
avec leur entre guillemets patrons qui
était le son national de transfusion
sanguine qui était à la fois le
laboratoire qui fabriquait les
médicaments et qui étaient aussi
l'employeur des prescripteurs de
produits et bien sûr qu'il savait au
point qu'un jour il a
tout en me faisant des ordonnances comme
aux autres patients
de ma région il écrivait à Georgina
Dufois il faut nous arrêter de combien
de sida seront nous responsables
en revanche et comme donc voilà ce que
disait votre médecin à la ministre en
charge des affaires sociales de l'époque
1984 fin 1995 ce documentaire que nous
venons noirs nous dit tout le monde
savait dans la communauté scientifique
parmi les pouvoirs publics ceux qui
devaient savoir savaient
et vous commencez à vous intéresser au
sujet en 86 et pourtant c'est toujours
une omerta concret c'est pour ça que
l'expression tout le monde savait est
une drôle d'expression parce que mais
c'est vrai que c'était le monde de
l'hémophilie le monde de la transfusion
était un monde très très particulier
très à part avec des relations aussi
très à pas des relations très fortes
entre les médecins qui soignaient ces
enfants ou ces personnes et les familles
c'était voilà totalement à part et moi
je me souviens au tout début du sida les
rapports entre les grandes associations
qui allaient se créer sur le sida
les gays ou les homosexuels les
hémophiles les aimaient pas beaucoup
donc ils étaient quelque chose de très
différent voilà c'était très particulier
et c'est vrai qu'en 86 ou quand moi je
commence à m'occuper de ces questions là
on en parle pas beaucoup et ce n'est
qu'un peu plus tard quelques années plus
tard au moins au journal on a eu des
gens qui sont venus les fameux deux
personnes qui s'appelaient les perrons
garvanov donc là voilà des hémophiles
qui et la première fois quand ils en
parlent vous ne les croyez pas c'est
tellement quand il vous raconte et puis
bon surtout que les à cette époque là
quand même ce qui est très ce qui est
terrible c'est que c'est pas c'est pas
un silence c'est un peu impensable que
des médecins qui pour la plupart étaient
des gens très bien et puis continuer
certaines pratiques et surtout quand on
le voit d'aujourd'hui sans en parler à
leur passion aujourd'hui c'est
impensable mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
oublié c'était des relations très
paternaliste dans le monde de la
médecine et le monde de la transfusion
sanguine l'était encore plus c'était
aussi un autre monde quoi et donc ça
arrive plus tard alors on savait enfin
84 parmi ceux qui étaient censés avoir
les connaissances pour savoir on va dire
les choses comme ça et pourtant il
faudra attendre le premier août 1985
pour que Laurent Fabius le Premier
ministre de l'époque annonce le
dépistage obligatoire concernant le VIH
il y a un véritable retard à l'allumage
qu'on perçoit très bien dans le
documentaire qu'on vient de voir
peut-être comparer à d'autres pays qui
avait pris déjà des mesures pour éviter
le
programme qu'on allait vivre nous en
France comment on explique sur Terre à
l'allumage et comment on explique cette
formidable
omerta qui a régné durant ces années sur
ce sujet précisément il y a un phénomène
international
au total 90% des hémophiles ont été
contaminés par le qui à l'époque
d'ailleurs on ne s'appelait pas VIH ça
plaît elle avait il faut dire que si à
l'époque dit en 84 tout le monde savait
tout le monde n'avait pas les
connaissances d'aujourd'hui on appelle
le concert gay aussi dans ce
documentaire au début des années en
cancer ni une maladie des homosexuels si
à l'époque on avait regardé en Afrique
il y avait plus de femmes atteintes que
d'hommes donc et de femmes
hétérosexuelle donc en réalité les les
notions étaient assez confuses en 83 à
l'Institut Pasteur de Paris était
découvert le virus qui s'appelait à
l'époque elle avait mais qui a été
contestée
pendant des mois et des années de telle
sorte que les tests s'appliquent à ce
virus certains disaient ça ne dépistent
pas vraiment le virus cause de la
maladie il y avait donc une certaine
confusion la confusion elle-même si loin
que quelques-uns très peu heureusement
disait chez les gens qui ont des
anticorps ça prouve qu'ils se défendent
bien contre le virus donc c'est pas
mauvais d'avoir des anticorps
croyant que ces anticorps protégeaient
ce qui n'est pas le cas bien sûr
maintenant on pourrait vous l'expliquer
très scientifiquement ces anticorps ne
pénètrent pas dans les cellules or le
virus VIH il est interdé des cellules
donc les anticorps ne protègent en rien
une fois que le virus est là mais enfin
84 on a la certitude le fait de chauffer
il y a une sorte une lenteur désactive
le virus 90% des hémophiles contaminés
ici aux États-Unis ou en Allemagne c'est
50 à 70%. donc vous voyez que c'est
quand même un phénomène important
partout mais pourquoi plus en France
qu'ailleurs ben je crois que Eric favrol
a dit il y avait un paternalisme
médical et particulièrement dans le
centre national tension sanguine qui
faisait qu'il n'était pas concevable de
d'émettre des idées mettant en cause ce
sang apporteur de vie les dérivés
sanguins qui résolvent les problèmes et
et les grands pontes qui étaient
responsables de cela et donc c'était
très très difficile d'oser d'oser
simplement mettre en cause cela et donc
les gens ont fait des alertes mais ces
alertes ont été en interne n'ont pas été
publiques et donc il y a eu des lettres
qui ont été adressées aux différents
responsables de l'administration des
ministères etc qui ont en définitivement
enclenché et si
c'est en juillet
85 que Laurent Fabius a déclenché ce
dépistage systématique
déjà à l'époque il a fallu aller contre
certaines inerties qui voulaient
empêcher ce message pourquoi à l'époque
dire qu'on allait dépister tous les
nerfs de sang
c'était osé mettre
une image négative sur le don de sang et
donc certains se sont
levés contre leur Fabius en disant il ne
faut pas que le don de sang puisse être
attaché à l'idée de transmission d'un
virus potentiellement mortel donc c'est
c'était vous voyez une atmosphère qui
était très curieuse et au bout du compte
cette lenteur cette inertie on pourrait
espérer que la leçon de l'histoire c'est
que ça ne se produise plus jamais après
et bien malheureusement et c'est pour ça
que je vous remercie de faire cette
émission malheureusement ça s'est
reproduit pour d'autres scandales
sanitaires prenant l'exemple vous l'avez
évoqué du Conseil Jacob après l'hormone
de croissance prenons l'exemple du
médiateur
le temps qui lui a fallu et les combats
qu'elle a dû mener pour faire entendre
le fait que on donnait en médicament qui
allait ravager les cœurs de certaines
personnes et aboutir à la mort de
plusieurs d'entre eux
or au tout début quand
les premières maladies apparaissent
c'est un peu inéluctable mais comment
admettre que pendant des années des
années un produit dangereux soit
administré comme c'était le cas ici et
quand Laurent Fabius a signé ce document
pour que les donneurs soient testés
il y a eu encore pendant des mois et des
mois et des mois l'utilisation de
produits qui avait été stockés et qui en
France n'était pas chauffée pour des
raisons de combat industriel qui
faisaient que c'est ses poches qui
étaient administrées à des malades
contenait du virus alors même qu'on
savait à l'époque détruire par le
chauffage le virus qu'on savait qu'on
aurait pu tester les donneurs et donc
c'est mort là sont encore plus
illégitimes que les autres et puis on
est au niveau quel nombre de victimes à
1350 hémophiles ont été contaminés à
l'occasion de ces transfusions durant
cette période fatid quelqu'un de début
85 jusqu'à
1085 et 1000 personnes contaminées parmi
ces hémophiles en sont malheureusement
décédés on va écouter un extrait du
documentaire ce fameux extrait de
l'émission 7 sur 7 nous sommes en
janvier
1992 sur chez les confrères de TF1 Anne
Sinclair interview Georgine a du froid
dont on parlait à l'instant et voilà ce
qu'elle répond
en affirme Perrier a eu ces bouteilles
d'eau contaminées par du benzène c'était
beaucoup moins grave le benzène que le
sida et néanmoins a retirer ses
bouteilles pourquoi est-ce que pour une
affaire des produits non chauffés on les
a pas immédiatement retirés écoutez-le
sans n'a rien à voir avec du Perrier
imaginez qu'on est retiré tout le sang
qui était à ce moment-là disponible ça
veut dire que combien de gens mouraient
je me sens tout à fait responsable pour
autant je me sens pas coupable
ça c'est le fameux responsable mais pas
coupable alors ça c'est resté comme
quelque chose de très marquant
concernant cette affaire il y a eu un
procès en 92 avec notamment Michel
gareta qui est condamné vous pouvez nous
faire le point de ceux qui ont payé
l'addition payer la facture de ce
scandale d'État
à travers ce procès de 92 et puis
ensuite bien sûr 99 ça c'est la Haute
Cour de Justice de la République qui
jugera dans une a du foie qu'on vient
d'entendre Laurent Fabius Premier
ministre de l'époque
bien sûr qui était le secrétaire d'État
à la santé à l'époque non parce que
c'est une histoire aussi qui est très
complexe parce que ce mail de choses un
petit peu différente que vous monsieur
que vous connaissez par coeur à savoir
qui a les histoires autour des produits
chauffés des produits pour les
hémophiles d'un côté avec cette chose
comme invraisemblable que de grosso modo
quoi de l'automne 84 à juillet 85 voilà
il y avait tous les éléments pour dire
on arrête on change le risque est trop
grand on fait autre chose ça c'est une
chose et puis il y a l'autre qui est le
volet autour du dépistage ou pour la des
raisons industrielles pour des raisons
économiques et politiques bizarrement on
voulait pas bizarrement on a toujours
voulu produire d'abord français et voilà
et on a voulu privilégier les grandes
entreprises françaises en particulier
pasteur etc alors qu'il y avait des
tests américains et donc on a un peu on
a retardé de quelques mois ceux
dépistage qui allait se faire donc pour
le premier procès autour des produits
chauffés il y a eu des comme
responsables évidemment le directeur du
CNTS qui était Michel garretta et puis
qui était une comment dirais une une
cible j'allais dire presque magnifique
parce que entre ça c'était quelqu'un
quand je me souviens de l'époque c'était
quelqu'un qui était extrêmement
péremptoire puissant etc il avait beau
ne pas être dans le monde de la médecine
professeure il était il avait beaucoup
de pouvoir il avait beaucoup d'argent et
puis il y avait beaucoup d'équipes
médicales qui avaient besoin de savoir
mais quelqu'un comme un prix le prix
Nobel absolument magnifique dossier il
avait besoin
de travailler avec le CNTs pour
récupérer toute une série d'échantillons
donc il était au centre de quelque chose
donc Michel garretta 4 ans de prison
ferme et puis après il y a eu 500000
francs de dédommagement de l'époque
et pour la petite histoire jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs monsieur vous
devez le savoir l'association française
hémophile est toujours comme on dirait
plus qu'en colère mais en trop c'est
contre le docteur parce que le docteur a
touché des indemnités de son départ et
il refuse de les donner et comme il
s'est fait de façon on ne sait pas où il
habite il a plus l'adresse et cetera
donc il y a une grosse somme de
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
que l'Association française des
hémophiles réclament que véritable alors
du côté médical Jean-Pierre Alain je
finis pardonner moi je lui tourne
Jean-Pierre Alain responsable du CNTS du
département rechercher développement lui
quatre ans de prison dont deux avec
sursis il y avait deux autres personnes
poursuivies dans ce procès de 92 pour
non-assistance à personne en danger
cette fois c'est Jacques Roux ancien
manière générale de la santé trois ans
de prison avec sursis et Robert Netter
ex directeur du Laboratoire national de
santé qui sera lui a quitté
et puis il y a ces responsables c'est
très responsabilité politique que toutes
les victimes ont cherché à établir avec
ces fameux procès de 99 de Laurent
fabuleux du foie Hervé
mais vous n'avez pas eu gain de cause
c'est là qu'il y a un ce fameux
responsable mais pas coupable et la
justice leur a donné raison la justice
ne peut agir que s'il y a des preuves
d'une part et une relation directe au
pénale en tout cas entre
la cause et une conséquence là il était
semble-t-il assez difficile de faire le
lien absolu entre
ce Corée su des ministres
au fur et à mesure du temps qui passait
et ce que leur ce qu'il aurait pris
comme décision ce que leur aurait dit
leur conseiller ministre a priori n'est
pas quelqu'un qui est
très scientifique qui n'est pas ils sont
pas tous disons des chercheurs ils sont
pas tous des gens qui sont capables de
connaître le le
fond de chaque problème en revanche sont
les grands absents sont quand même les
médecins prescripteurs qui là ont été en
quelque sorte
pas gracier mais par une loi qui sur les
délines en intentionnelle qui a permis
qui était ni une loi qui concernait les
mères qui étaient attaqués pour
un poteau de basket qui blessait un
enfant et qui jouait et cette loi servi
à exonéré en quelque sorte beaucoup de
gens
du côté des victimes y a-t-il eu des
indemnisations
ont-elles été importante
d'indemnisations concernant les victimes
et les proches de ses victimes alors il
y a eu des
deux étapes d'une part une proposition
amiable en quelque sorte qui était très
faible et puis la raie courtelle mon
l'arrêt courtellement c'était une dame
qui avait été contaminée par une
étudiant et là la cour d'appel a donné
des sommes qui étaient beaucoup plus
élevées qui étaient je dirais plus en
rapport avec le préjudice qui était
infligés on peut avoir une idée des
sommes qui ont été allouées en moyenne à
ceux et celles qui ont été victime
c'est-à-dire mais ce serait quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros quand même
et
on est passé de 10000 euros par exemple
à quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
et là effectivement les gens qui ont par
victime nous sommes d'accord qui ont
déposé des recours soit devant le
tribunal administratif parce que c'était
en fonction de du statut du centre de
transfusion soit devant le tribunal
civil ont eu effectivement pour la
plupart des indemnités je dirais correct
eu égard au préjudice qui était alors ça
c'était pour les conséquences
judiciaires
sur le plan sanitaire quelles
conséquence et qu'elle le sont ont tiré
les pouvoirs publics de cette fameuse
affaire dans les années qui ont suivi il
y a eu une réorganisation complète déjà
du centre de transfusion qui a été
scindé en plusieurs parties notamment
l'Établissement français du sang qui
maintenant s'occupe de la FS voilà la
collecte du sang et les transfusions
sanguines et un autre organisme qui fait
les les laboratoire laboratoire
LFB qui fait le fractionnement qui qui
extrait du plasma différents produits
qui servent au traitement donc c'est une
question un peu de biotechnologie cette
fois c'est pas le le sans lui-même c'est
la production alors ceci a évité ce
mastodonte qui était devenu le centre
transfusion et l'excès de pouvoir qu'il
y avait dans les mains d'un seul homme
qui en avait malheureusement abusé et
qui avait recherché des intérêts
mercantiles tout à fait inapproprié et
qui avait oublié son obligation de
prudence et de sécurité et donc c'est un
petit peu la leçon qui a été étirée les
choses se sont je crois on va éviter de
nouveaux drames sanitaires
Jacob c'est vrai par exemple et on a
soumis le sang et ses dérivés au même
analyses investigation contrôle que les
autres médicaments et donc c'est devenu
quelque chose qui a été banalisé et
mieux mais il faut voir les
inconvénients par contre qui qui
existent aujourd'hui et qui font qu'on a
d'autres scandales potentiels pendant
que l'exemple du traitement par les
immunoglobulines c'est nous expliquer
oui l'immidoine c'est ce sont des
molécules qui sont dans le sang et qui
sont les anticorps on est d'accord et
les anticorps tous ceux qui sont nés
sans anticorps ont besoin de cela pour
vivre et donc on leur fait des
perfusions de ces de ces anticorps bien
en France la production est effectuée
par ce laboratoire dont je viens de vous
parler avant c'était le centre de
transfusion qu'elle faisait et bien
maintenant ce laboratoire le fait mais
il le fait dans les conditions très
rigoureuses avec des règles éthiques
malheureusement les contraintes qui
existent font que ils produisent de quoi
satisfaire à peu près la moitié de la
demande donc la moitié des malades ne
pourrait pas en France qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on l'achète à l'étranger mais
l'étranger n'applique pas les mêmes
règles pour la production en particulier
sur le plan éthique en France le don du
sang vous le savez se fait de façon
volontaire gratuite etc les autres pays
la plupart d'entre eux payent les
donneurs de sang et du coup
en France nous sommes amenés à traiter
la moitié de ces malades avec des
produits produits dans des conditions
que la loi française interdit chaque
année il faut faire une dérogation à la
loi pour dire nous allons traiter non là
par nécessité puisque on en produit pas
assez en apportant des produits mais ces
produits ne sont pas faits selon les
règles éthiques que la France s'impose
et donc vous voyez qu'on a encore un
certain nombre de choses qui donc
attention vous dites là dans ce cas là
danger
oui oui il va falloir un jour ou l'autre
soit soit on modifie les règles éthiques
si on pense qu'on peut pas les appliquer
soit
on se débrouille pour produire de façon
satisfaisante les quantités aujourd'hui
le laboratoire qui les produit il
aborderave B considère que en France on
ne collecte pas assez de sang pour
produire tout ce qui est nécessaire du
coup nous sommes dépendants d'autres
pays vous voyez ce que je veux dire
absolument
autre conséquence c'est là alors je vous
laisse réagir allez-y parce que on
l'oublie aujourd'hui mais ça a été un
choc terrible à faire connaissance et ça
s'est traduit en tout cas d'un point de
vue structuré d'administratif par un
bouleversement total a été quand même
ont été créés les grandes agences
sanitaires en particulier l'agent du
médicament comme vous dites
l'Établissement Français du sein du sang
puis après il y avait eu l'histoire
aussi de l'alimentation etc il y a eu
une prise de conscience absolument
énorme et surtout il y a eu un
basculement on l'oublie mais jusque
jusqu'à l'affaire du sang la médecine
c'était regardé comme que des belles
épopées tout allait bien les médicaments
etc et d'un coup elle est rentrée dans
l'ère du scandale il y a eu depuis
l'affaire du ça on ne regardait ça a été
vraiment une image très fort une cassure
aussi très forte vis-à-vis du monde
médical parce que quand même des
médecins voilà il y avait la confiance
que peuvent avoir les patients en leur
médecin et en même temps et en même
temps c'était l'époque où se développait
ou c'est malheureusement beaucoup
propagé le sida avec la création
d'associations de malades l'Association
française des hémophiles n'étaient pas
une association de malade c'était une
association de médecins qui avait des
hémophiles dans grosso modo après ça a
totalement changé la Ligue nationale
contre le cancer c'était une association
de médecins qui avait été là avec
l'arrivée et c'était vrai le
bouleversement c'est de l'arrivée du
SIDA et le scandale du sang crée un
nouvel acteur qui dit attendez moi j'ai
le droit à la parole je ne peux pas
faire confiance de façon abrupte au
médecin et aux progrès médical et aux
structures administratives puisque les
structures administratives voilà bien vu
elles sont un peu doux donc on est voilà
c'est pour ça que ça a été un
bouleversement extrêmement fort autre
conséquence
Eric Favreau c'est la sélection très
drastique des donneurs alors après là on
rentre dans voilà dans quelque chose de
se dire de plus technique voilà mais la
sélection c'est vrai très drastique des
Donats mais même regardez le débat
technique mais à la fois très pratique
parce que j'ai lu quand même qu'il y
avait près de 4,1 million de dons en 80
mais en 2020 il y en avait plus il n'y
en a plus que 2,8 millions aujourd'hui
donc il y a une vraie défiance
et qui est encore est très d'actualité
c'est est-ce que les gays peuvent donner
leur sang il y a eu une mobilisation
depuis quelques temps pour dire mais
c'est inadmissible il doit pouvoir
donner l'ordre 83 et 2016 les personnes
homosexuelles ne pouvaient pas donner
leur et on avait raison et je ne suis
pas sûr que l'on est toujours raison de
dire c'est pas parce que comme c'était
un don on se dit on va pas empêcher les
donneurs mais non c'est pas un c'est pas
canon il y a aussi des devoirs et vous
voyez des grosses associations qui sont
quand même pas comment dirais-je lourde
de critiques comme l'association n elle
était jusqu'à récemment très réticente à
ce qu'il y ait une ouverture du don du
sang au quel que soit quelque soit la
situation vous voyez c'est c'est le
risque c'est c'est compliqué voilà mais
il y a eu telle pression voilà
sur la sélection des donneurs qui a été
mise en place assez vite ensuite à la
suite de cette affaire
drastique il y a un questionnaire vous
si vous donnez votre sang vous devez
remplir aujourd'hui un questionnaire
sans avoir à stipuler son orientation
sexuelle ça ça a changé depuis 2022
c'est assez récent mais jusque là
tout à fait l'Association française des
hémophiles était d'ailleurs un peu
réticente comme aide
en disant qu'effectivement on pouvait
avoir
des on a une période silencieuse dans
les tests qui est maintenant limité je
crois une semaine ou quelque chose comme
ça un moment où un donneur de sang ne
peut pas être détecté on peut pas
détecter dans son sang un virus est-ce
que c'est un risque quelle élévation du
risque je pense que le gouvernement a
décidé que non
maintenant ce que je voudrais rappeler
quand même c'est que depuis de faire du
sans contaminé où les affaires du sang
contaminées et un nouvel acteur qui est
arrivé qui s'appelle l'Europe
et la Commission européenne a édictée et
à cet été publié une nouvelle mouture
d'un règlement qui concerne toutes les
substances qui sont issues de leur qui
sont d'origine humaine et qui sont le
sang les tissus et les cellules et qui
sont
ce texte est à l'étude dans les États
membres et qui est assez drastique quand
même sur le plan de de la sécurité sur
le plan de de l'éthique etc et je pense
que cet acteur là amène une sécurité
supplémentaire de la même manière que
peuvent l'amener
les agences que peuvent amener les
médecins qui maintenant sont quand même
beaucoup plus vigilants les associations
de patients qui
d'objets sont devenus des sujets sont
devenus des acteurs de santé publique
alors avec on peut imaginer comme
difficulté parce que
tout le monde n'est pas médecin et amené
une problématique de patience et
c'est compliqué il existe un collectif
de 70 associations de patients qui
s'appelle français santé et qui
intervient dans de nombreuses instances
que ce soit la Haute Autorité de Santé
le le conseil de santé publique que ce
soit la NSM l'Agence du médicament pour
amener un regard qui soit
complémentaire ou différents
terminé c'est qu'il nous faut accroître
notre réactivité notre adaptabilité à
des circonstances différentes autant il
était légitime il a été même important
indispensable à un moment donné
d'exclure du don de sang
les personnes homosexuelles ou
bisexuelles les personnes en prison les
Haïtiens les drogués toxicoman tout cela
ont été exclus du don de sang parce que
le risque qu'il transmet une maladie
mortelle était redoutable donc c'était
légitime à ce moment-là et ensuite
maintenant la l'évolution de cette
épidémie la prise en charge
thérapeutique la
rareté des personnes non dépistées ayant
ces virus fait que le risque n'est plus
du tout du tout du tout le même et donc
aujourd'hui ça devient de la
discrimination que de ne pas accepter le
don de sang venant de donner homosexuels
qui n'ont pas de risque très différents
de le transmettre que un autre
hétérosexuel qui aurait eu plusieurs
partenaires récemment donc vous voyez
bien que il faut être capable de
s'adapter
l'épidémie de covid récent nous montre
aussi la même chose il nous faut
accroître la capacité de réagir il faut
être plus agile dans nos adaptations aux
circonstances qui sont très variables et
il faut pas se baser sur des le grand
principe nous sommes tous contre la
discrimination évidemment nous sommes
tous mais à un moment donné si une
catégorie de personnes transmet une
maladie mortelle on est obligé de dire
attention on protégeant et donc vous
voyez c'est pas
méfions-nous d'un principe universel qui
irait contre l'intérêt général ça a été
pareil avec le covid ou il y a eu des
fois des mesures un petit peu excessives
parce que regardez quand on a on a privé
même les mourants dans les EHPAD de
contact avec leurs familles bon on a
oublié quand même cette nécessité autant
pour la personne en agonie que pour ses
proches d'avoir un contact dans ces
cette période terrible et du coup on les
a privés pour protéger mais ça veut dire
que la réflexion qui est protégée avoir
de l'humanité tout ceci doit se
réfléchir chaque moment donné dans des
circonstances qu'on évalue à un moment
donné avec des connaissances qui sont
généralement imparfaites parce que c'est
vrai que en 84 85 on n'avait pas les
connaissances complètes d'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que au début du covid on
n'avait pas les connaissances complètes
d'aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que dans les
problèmes de demain on va devoir aussi
s'adapter avec les moyens du bord mais
il faut aller plus vite on est un peu
trop lent il y a trop d'inertie dans le
système
eric va vous jouer
il y a eu le changement et technique etc
maintenant les pouvoirs publics les
autorités gèrent pas mal le risque ils
savent mais c'est pas ça je trouve le
problème et c'est pas ça la leçon qui
n'a pas été tirée c'est il y a aussi une
confusion des gens et des acteurs qui a
posé problème dans l'affaire du sang et
qui pose toujours problème entre
l'acteur qui fait qui est là pour faire
de l'argent et l'autre qui est pour
faire de la santé le médecin les
patients il y a les agences
l'indépendance des agences vis-à-vis des
pouvoir politique tout ça a été révélé
par l'affaire du sort mais comme tous
ces cristallisé autour de garetha il y
avait un méchant et quelques voilà voilà
il y avait quand même une confusion un
entre-soi un peu généralisé et ça ça a
été très mal décortiqué et on en a tiré
très peu de leçons comme on l'a vu après
dans l'affaire du Médiator ou la faire
du médiateur c'est un mélange des gens
entre l'administration ce qui décide
même s'il y a un responsable premier un
coupable qui était en l'occurrence et
servi voilà et c'est ça je trouve la
grande frustration qu'on peut avoir si
aujourd'hui le risque est perçu même les
politiques ils sont obsédés par la
gestion du risque etc mais l'autre volet
qui est la place de chacun et la non
confusion du genre là malheureusement je
trouve qu'on n'a pas fait beaucoup de
progrès bah ce sera le mot de la fin
Éric Favreau merci un grand merci
vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc consacré
aujourd'hui à l'affaire du sang
contaminé dont je rappelle que vous avez
fait partie des victimes de de cette
fameuse à faire et des transfusions
sanguines qui ont eu lieu entre
la fin 1984 et le milieu de l'année
1985 vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag
des Badoc bien entendu sur Twitter merci
aussi à sel massadi comme à la coutumée
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission et
puis je vous retrouve tout simplement
pour un prochain débat doc avec bien sûr
son documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]